[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation les mers et les océans
sont au coeur des échanges puisque 90%
du trafic mondial en valeur et en volume
se fait par bateau dans ce cadre on
parle régulièrement de la mer de chine
par où passe le tiers du commerce
international dans l'affrontement
croissant entre la chine et les états
unis
une part importante des incidents se
font autour de taïwan et en berdu des
américains voulant protéger leurs alliés
taïwanais réclame la libre circulation
de leurs marines militaires tandis que
les chinois mettent en place une
stratégie maritime globale qui s'appuie
sur une marine puissante et la
revendication d'un espace maritime
permettant se protéger dans les deux cas
on applique le concept que rappelle
l'amiral colle deux filles dans la revue
esprit corse et en numéro 161 on ne
possède pas la mer on maîtrise la
capacité d'y naviguer
un peu d'histoire quand en 1949 l'armée
communiste chinoise mao tsé toung a
défait l'armée nationaliste chinoise du
maréchal tchiang kaï chek
celui ci s'est replié avec ses partisans
sur l'île de formose
c'était un territoire occupé par les
japonais
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre qui avait
été donné à la chine par les alliés
tandis qu'abou proclamé la république
populaire de chine le 1er octobre 1949
le maréchal qui étaient appuyés
politiquement et financièrement par les
états unis s'est déclarée le 1er mars
1950 président de la république de chine
avec la ferme intention de revenir sur
le continent
mais devant la montée en puissance de la
chine populaire
il signa en 1954 un traité de défense
mutuelle avec les états unis
bien entendu celui ci fut dénoncé avec
vigueur par les communistes chinois qui
considère taïwan comme faisant partie de
la grande chine depuis son attribution
en 1945 en 1971 l'onu vota le
remplacement de taïwan par la chine
populaire comme membre de l'organisation
considérant qu'il n'y avait qu'une seule
chine et que le plus important des deux
devait la représenter ceci a affaibli
durablement la petite république
d'autant qu'à cette époque les
américains se rapprochaient de pékin
mais les américains n'ont pas lâché
leurs alliés démocratiques et u11 promis
comme vient de le confirmer anthony
blinken le secrétaire d'état du
président byden de lui donner la
capacité de se défendre en cas d'attaqué
en dépit des tensions encouragés par les
deux blocs
les discussions menées dans les années
90 pour un rapprochement n'ont pas
abouti dans une deuxième tentative en
2015 les présidents des deux chine se
sont serré la main et on est toujours
loin d'un accord
durant ces 45 dernières années la
démocratie à régime présidentiel
taïwanaise a connu un développement
économique exceptionnelle puisque cette
île de 24 millions d'habitants qui est
située à 180 km de la côte chinoise
avait en 2018
le 23ème pib mondial selon le fonds
monétaire international
contrairement à l'image d'opposition
totale entre les deux pays
il faut savoir que le quart des échanges
dans les deux sens se faisait avec la
chine et nombre d'industries taïwanaises
ont leur usine de l'autre côté du
détroit dans la province du fujian
c'est pourquoi selon la position
politique du président du parti au
pouvoir à taipei et selon les rapports
qu'il entretient avec les deux grandes
puissances
le positionnement de l'île oscille entre
le souhait de préserver une très large
autonomie et l'affirmation d'une
indépendance absolue
il n'en reste pas moins que taïwan est
marqué sur toutes les cartes de la chine
rouge comme une province chinoise mais
il est aussi certain que les événements
récents hong kong ont renforcé le camp
des indépendantistes
comme l'a rappelé en octobre 2018 dans
défense et industrie
marc julienne chercheur associé à la
fondation de l'arche recherche
stratégique
les chinois n'avait jusqu'en 1980 qu'une
défense côtière visant à repousser des
attaques venues de taiwan et celle plus
au nord venus de russie depuis 1981 tout
a changé
car la stratégie chinoise est devenue
globale sous l'impulsion de l'amiral liu
huaqing elle est construite autour de
trois objectifs la défense côtière la
défense active des mers proches
s'inscrivant dans la protection de la
souveraineté des intérêts maritimes en
temps de paix et la capacité de combat
naval avec riposte nucléaire en cas de
guerre le deuxième objectif correspond
aux espaces maritimes se trouvant à
l'intérieur de la première chaîne d'îles
au tour de la chine constitué de
l'archipel japonais
taïwan les philippines brunei
l'indonésie et lé un malaise
considéré comme une sorte de mer
intérieure ils sont définis par ce que
les chinois appellent la ligne des neuf
traille qui a été fixée unilatéralement
par eux en 1947
ce deuxième objectif inclut également la
protection des voies de communication
maritimes dont le détroit de malacca
car la chine en est actuellement
totalement dépendante pour ses
exportations et ses approvisionnements
s'y ajoutent les opérations militaires
autre que la guerre comme par exemple la
piraterie ou l'évacuation de
ressortissants lors de la crise de 1995
1996 dans le détroit de taiwan les
chinois ont subi la domination totale
des groupes aéronavals de la 7e flotte
de l'us navy
cette humiliation les a indiscutablement
encourager à construire une marine
hauturière projetable sur tous les
océans
elle a été présentée dans une optique
défensive et de développement pacifique
jusqu'à fin 2012 et l'arrivée du
président ping ping
les livres blancs de 2013 2015 ont
ensuite amplifié lourds de la marine
qu'on appelle la plan dans la capacité
de s'emparer et de conserver la
supériorité navale d'être en mesure de
contrôler les voies de communication
maritimes en mer de chine entend guère
de combattre dans les mers proches et de
disposer d'une puissante capacité
nucléaire alors que le budget défense
américain total a augmenté de 6 3% du
pib soit 728 milliards en 2020 celui de
la défense chinoise est passée de 5,9 à
5,2 pour cent du pib chinois soit 260
milliards en 2020 pourtant la croissance
et la modernisation des équipements de
la marine chinoise sont impressionnants
en 2019
la chine a construit en une année on ne
paie plus de bâtiments que les états
unis en quatre en guerre de 1941 à 1945
selon le crs américain même si leurs
performances moyennes sont inférieurs
l'appelant disposerait aujourd'hui de
333 à 360 unités tandis que l' us navy
alignait 297 bâtiment fin 2020 si aux
250 garde-côtes chinois dont certains
bâtiments ont carrément l'aspect de
beaux navires de combat repas en blanc
on ajoutait la milice navale on
arriverait autour de 700 bâtiments
disponibles
à titre de comparaison on peut ajouter
que sur la base de 2019
tous les trois ans la chine construit
l'équivalent de la flotte militaire
française qui est la première de l'union
européenne face à cette situation
l'us navy a demandé une augmentation
budgétaire de 60 milliards de dollars
pour atteindre un budget annuel de 200
milliards de dollars soit l'équivalent
des quatre cinquièmes du budget total de
la défense chinoise et son objectif est
de posséder plus de 5 130 navires de
guerre en 2050
certes comme l'analyse guerric poncet
dans le poids du 2 mai elle a encore des
faiblesses les systèmes d'armes
défensives de nouvelle génération
les technologies de l'information la
formation et l'entraînement
l'interopérabilité entre les navires le
commandement et les autres armés en
particulier avec la composante aérienne
mais elle s'améliore rapidement
si l'on en juge par les trois nouveaux
bateaux mis en service le 23 avril à la
base navale de sagna et ceci est
confirmé par l'amiral pierre vandier
chef d'état major de la marine nationale
reconnaissant qu'il leur manque le
savoir-faire opérationnelles détenues
par les marines occidentales mais qu'ils
s'organisent pour l'acquérir
pour comprendre la stratégie chinoise en
mer de chine
on est obligé de se référer à la
convention de montego bay voté sous
l'égide de l'onu en 1982 qui définit les
droits de la mère mise en oeuvre à
partir de 1994
elle fixe les règles de la souveraineté
maritime et les conditions
d'exploitation de cet espace en juin
elle avait été signée par 168 pays dont
la chine et la france mais pas par les
états unis qui font pourtant sans cesse
référence en invoquant la libre
circulation ce navire militaire en
dehors des eaux territoriales au delà de
cette limite traditionnelle la
convention de montego bay reconnaît que
les zones correspondant
approximativement au plateau continental
et s'étendant sur 200 milles nautiques
sont des aides
c'est à dire des zones économiques
exclusives des pays rivera cette
opportunité encouragé la chine en 2009 à
revendiquer à l'onu une zone maritime de
2 millions de kilomètres carrés en
jouant sur les limites du plateau
continental et en s'appropriant les
archipels de petits îlots et récifs
coralliens qui s'y trouvent
les premiers aménagements avaient débuté
avant dès 1988 sur le récif de johnson
du sud dans les spratleys depuis 2015
elle a transformé un certain nombre de
ces archipels en base militaire il est
vrai qu'au delà de son importance dans
le commerce maritime mondial
la mer de chine recèle de nombreuses
ressources allant de la pêche aux
hydrocarbures et aux nodules mineo qui
intéresse les pays riverains
cette extension imposé même discutable
lui permet de contrôler les eaux
environnantes mais d'exploiter librement
les ressources de cet espace en dépit du
mécontentement des pays riverains les
incidents multiples autour des îles
spratly
sangoku ou paracels nous le rappellent
régulièrement mes analyses et
l'installation des bases militaires sur
les récifs des îles spratleys wire comme
étant seulement la conséquence de la
volonté d'extension de la zi chinoise
serait une erreur majeure
conformément à sa stratégie globale
la chine veut également sécuriser ses
lignes d'approvisionnement et les
futures routes maritimes de la soie vers
l'europe et l'afrique
la piraterie et la lutte contre le
terrorisme font partie de ces objectifs
comme on l'a vu dans l'océan indien où
elle a envoyé 36 flottis de lutte anti
piraterie dans le golfe d'aden depuis
il faut savoir qu'une attaque terroriste
coulant trois gros bateaux dans le
passage suffirait à bloquer le détroit
de malacca pour longtemps c'est pourquoi
la stratégie navale dit des colliers de
perles qui assure une efficacité
maximale de l'appelant dans sa mission
implante des bases navales
tout au long de la route de la soie qui
relie la chine au golfe arabo persique
en commençant par les récifs pour
terminer par la base militaire de
djibouti et celle qui sera bientôt
opérationnelle en iran considérant que
les deux fait partie de son territoire
la chine conteste le principe de transit
inoffensif qui permet à un navire
militaire de passer à distance
raisonnable des côtes d'un autre pays
s'il ne se montre pas menaçants et ne
mènent pas d'activité inamicale
récemment un sous marin et un bateau
support français ont patrouillé en mer
de chine dans les eaux revendiquées par
pékin
un destroyer de l' us navy est passé
dans le détroit de taiwan début février
et deux porte avions américains ont
opéré en mer de chine du sud
quel
jours plus tard ils ont été en
permanence
suivi par des avions et des bateaux
chinois d'un côté comme de l'autre ce
furent du gesticulations et des
démonstrations de force pour jauger
l'adversaire
sur le plan du droit c'est légal mais
dans la pratique cela s'inscrit dans une
volonté chinoise de remise en cause du
droit international de la mer
nathalie guibert dans le monde du 5 mars
constate qu'en affichant ainsi sa
souveraineté en mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
ce n'est évidemment pas du goût des
occidentaux il considère que la z 2
donne des droits souverains sur
l'exploitation mais pas sur la
souveraineté
l'amiral christophe prazuck directeur de
l'institut de l'océan de l'alliance
sorbonne universités juge normal que
chacun essaie de tirer avantage du droit
le problème est qu'on trouve pas de
compromis la militarisation de la mer de
chine du sud
dénoncé par les états unis est une
légitime défense pour le régime du xi
jinping lazer 2e n'est plus
exclusivement économiques pour pékin
mais aussi zone de sécurité ce qui
réduit la liberté de navigation voulue
par washington au seul bateau civil
parmi les trois objectifs fixés à la
marine chinoise
le premier sur la défense côtière est
largement réalisée avec l'ensemble des
navires concernés et le matériel
amphibie qui pourrait employer vers
taïwan en cas de volonté d' invasion
elle semble peu probable car
contrairement aux affirmations
occidental les chinois n'y ont aucun
intérêt et connaissent parfaitement la
valeur du temps qui passe
risquer une guerre majeure pour cette
île n'a pas de sens
il suffit d'attendre patiemment que leur
niveau de vie deviennent similaire que
les échanges s'amplifie et que les
politiques à taïwan y soit favorable
pour entamer un processus de
rapprochement qui est inéluctable dans
le temps
la position de taiwan est celle d'un
porte-avions à courte portée de la côte
chinoise
elle représente donc un intérêt certain
au plan stratégique pour l'amérique dans
son bras de fer avec la chine
la menace de son invasion est brandie
par les américains pour justifier leurs
actions sur zone et des demandes de
budgets de défense complémentaires quant
aux taiwanais c'est aussi un moyen
d'obtenir des avantages de la part des
occidentaux
le deuxième axe sur la défense des voies
de communication se met en place avec le
développement d'une flotte de guerre
hauturière bénéficiant de ports d'escale
de maintenance et de ravitaillement en
mer de chine plus tout le long de la
route de la soie et en même temps
l'ouverture de routes terrestres et
ferroviaires
s'accompagnant par la mise en place de
gazoducs et d'oléoducs depuis
moyen-orient diminueront la part du
risque stratégique pour la défense de la
partie de la mer de chine considéré
comme leur mère intérieur le
développement de la flotte actuelle est
la proximité de ses bases devraient leur
donner
l'efficacité nécessaire pour remplir la
mission
le problème sera essentiellement
politique
sachant que la pression des pays
étrangers sera inversement
proportionnelle au niveau de fermeture
de la zone aux marines étrangères
qu'elles soient régionales ou occidental
à quel niveau
la chine souhaite maintenir la taille de
la zone dite des neuf très veut-elle en
faire une vraie et 2 ou une zone
réservée est souveraine et dans quel
délai il reste le troisième objectif qui
est celui de la confrontation opéré par
une guerre navale utilisant nucléaire
le film de promotion récemment diffusé
sur la marine chinoise est très
instructif car il montre qu elle se
pense prête ou du moins veulent faire
croire
pourtant selon l'article en asie 21 d'un
des meilleurs spécialistes français de
la chine général scheffer
les chinois ont encore un gros problème
à résoudre qui justifie à lui seul
l'intérêt de la mer intérieure la base
des sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins chinois dsn elle est à sanya
dans l'île de haïnan
un peu au sud de la chine or la
persistance du plateau continental
empêche les sous marins de plongée en
eaux profondes jusqu'au détroit de bachy
entre les philippines et taïwan
l'idéal sont dans t'es un point proche
de la côte est de cette dernière
cette contrainte les rend facilement
repérables par les bateaux qui
patrouillent dans la zone et les
systèmes de surveillance étrangers ils
peuvent être identifiées suivi et
détruit avant d'arriver dans la zone de
tir de leurs missiles longue portée
pour pouvoir garantir l'effet de
dissuasion nucléaire il est donc
impératif que l'appelant contrôler
entièrement la zone et y empêche toute
présence étrangère pour sécuriser la
sortie de leurs sous marins vers le
pacifique
dans ce cadre l'importance de l'aser 2
la définition en zone réservée prend une
toute autre dimension
on comprend également la position de la
marine américaine qui a évidemment tout
intérêt à ce que les sous marins chinois
soient confinés dans le sud de la mer de
chine et qu'elle puisse circuler dans la
zone pour les surveiller on peut y
ajouter aussi que taiwan reste dans
l'orbité occidental
comme les flics très clairement françois
martin dans son article du 17 mars 2021
dans smart reading presse si demain un
conflit ouvert ce produit entre la chine
et les usa
on peut penser qu'il se déroulera dans
la mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement stratégie
pour les deux puissances mais pour en
arriver là il faudrait que ce produit
cette montée aux extrêmes que graham
allison appelle le piège de thucydide
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
remonter ou tir dépassé par une
puissance émergente la tentation normale
et de la détruire au plan politique ou
militaire avant qu'elle n'arrive à ses
fins c'est à l'évidence ce qui se passe
devant nos yeux et qui va amener toute
une série de mouvements stratégiques de
part et d'autre la chine est en position
de challenger agressif voulant retrouver
une place qu'elle a perdu il y a deux
cents ans après s'être focalisée très
longtemps sur a réussi la mairie vient
de prendre conscience depuis peu de
temps qu'à la vitesse de la progression
chinoise elle ne pourra bientôt plus
avoir l'avantagé pour insuffisant pour
être sûr de gagner et maintenir son
leadership et de toute manière le prix
humain à payer dans un conflit de ce
type sera très lourd pour les deux
parties nous rentrons donc dans une
période de quelques années où le piège
peut fonctionner si les deux puissances
et deux très grandes puissances ne sont
pas capables de maîtriser la situation
et résoudre leur conflit de leadership
par la négociation
à bientôt
[Musique]